that looks pretty good right there that
looks good okay that looks all right
they look like the swamp from Star Wars
[Music]
[Music]
I eat to live but I don't lift my diets
pretty much Chipotle in and out
Soylent in theory is really cool but in
practice it just seems terrifying I'm
pretty strong when I hate this if I come
out of this and my life has changed yeah
I'll say oh you eat my words and say I
was wrong but I don't think I'm gonna be
wrong I think it'll be great though I
have high hopes I am really scared to
give up food but I'm also very excited
to try something new and stick to it it
is day one we're about to make our
Soylent for the first time and to do
that we have packet of Soylent ice and
water and a bunch of oil and that's it
that's a meal that's cooked here's to a
great week of being sludge buds this is
morning one after a full day of Soylent
I thought simultaneously full and hungry
all day yesterday friends eating a
hamburger I have never been more jealous
of anyone in my life and I have a theme
right now
well Wednesday lunch is here but I'm not
gonna be having any of that here's what
I'm having oh hey look there's some
vomit on the stairs here's my dinner
he's having a great time clean your
plate shoulda Patrick it's day four
I've been eating luck since Tuesday I'm
sad and kind of delirious so earlier
this week we calculated how many
calories we needed to eat and I've been
following that pretty closely I haven't
been feeling too hungry the other night
I was falling asleep and I just started
thinking about bread it has saved me a
lot of time some bread is like very
porous and airy pooped like one time
this entire process which is [ __ ]
because I love pooping other breads like
cakey I definitely feel like Soylent is
a lot healthier than the usual garbage I
put in my body what was the question so
as far as the physical benefits of
eating like a nutritionally balanced
paste it seems to be working out ok
Oh company's getting talk later what a
fabulous day for them do you think it's
cheating if we eat beer drink beer and
Soylent diet personally you have my
blessing that is good good morning
everybody
you know what today is today is the last
day of Soylent I [ __ ] up I ate a
cookie I'd feel pretty guilty about it
but I also feel incredible I've had my
dinner at my last Soylent meal so here
we are
[Music]
Oh
past week there were a lot of highs and
lows there's a real rollercoaster of
emotion by last three and a half pounds
I think that's important state the facts
out right now you lost somewhere around
five pounds I don't think I need to lose
weight that wasn't my goal here I
actually gained two pounds while on
Soylent I can see the benefits because I
did save a bunch of time on it I think
if you're a really busy person who
doesn't have time to cook or to eat
healthily then Soylent is a very good
alternative after this interview is done
I'm gonna go into a straight shame
spiral and just gorge myself
foods great don't don't ever take food
for granted it's the best do Soylent if
you think it might be right for you but
we and yourself into it it's just so sad
what's happening over there oh yeah you
don't know the half of it
[Music]